Hi all,
today's objective is to demonstrate the
proof of technology demo on what we are
able to do with e-mail tagging for the
Connector Pro application for capital
markets.
The objective of this proof of tech demo
is to showcase the capabilities of the AI
engine that can tag clients information,
extract data from emails, attachments,
etc and categorize them for consumption
into key platforms such as Connector Pro,
which will allow us to avoid manual
efforts and repurpose towards other high
value work.
The scope for this proof of tech is to
sync up user emails with corresponding
Salesforce accounts by installing a
Salesforce Outlook plugin and then to
deploy an AI engine to scan the emails
from Salesforce user account and extract
the data and loop it back into Salesforce
to create tasks,
notes or chatter posts in this process.
So how do we get started?
We install the Salesforce plugin on
Outlook apps.
The next step would be to see the
Salesforce plugin in action.
Where the Outlook plugin will sync up the
emails to the user Salesforce account.
So I go to my mailbox,
I search for the e-mail based on some of
the keywords that I know and as you can
see I'm opening the e-mail and I'm
running the plugin which I've installed.
As you can see,
I'm using this profile and it is already
extracted the contact information about
who's the sender, who's the receiver,
what account and so forth.
Now we're logging in and this category
has been added and the e-mail has also
been added to Salesforce through the
plugin.
Now the next step is we are viewing the
tagged e-mail on Salesforce Sandbox where
the user logs into the Salesforce and
triggers a scan e-mail function.
As you can see,
the account is mapped out upon our
residency.
We can see that the e-mail is also there,
but there are no additional activities or
open activities that have been captured
because the e-mail is not scanned yet.
So we click on the e-mail,
we open it and we are able to see the
e-mail which has been extracted.
We run the scan e-mail function and in
the back end you can see the AI engine
extracting and categorizing the
information which then is pushed back and
looped back into Salesforce.
So when I go back and see my account
details,
you will see that there are two new open
activities that have been added.
One is a task with the checkbox and the
other one is an activity and you can
further edit it as per your needs at that
point.
Now all of this will be automated,
but we're currently showing the proof of
tech.
So now I go I look into my accounts now
this since it's upper in our residency,
I'm looking at the accounts.
The beauty is I'm able to access chat out
and I'm able to tag relevant groups and
give them like information or like pull
them into the conversation.
So what have we solved so far?
So with the current progress made,
we're able to prove that the AI engine's
capability to extract relevant
information from emails that have been
ingested through the plugin.
We're able to extract that information.
We're also able to loop that information
back into the Salesforce application and
then further on create Tasks and Chatter
posts and Tag groups, relevant groups.
So thanks for watching this proof of tech
demo and looking forward to the next
steps.